[Musique]
faut que je vous raconte le truc de
dingue qui m'est arrivé c'est quoi cette
histoire de dn à elle a dit qu en l'état
on savait pas c'est l'adn trouvé était
le vôtre ou celui de votre frère jumeau
j'ai pas de frère vas-y manon aussi si
j'avais un frère jumeau je le sens en
fait si j'en ai un cauchemar
et c'est lui c'est ce voilà quoi il a la
politique dans le sang beaulieu c'est
mon frère qu'engrais lourd elle
apprendra y sera très très chaude le
pauvre apprendre qu'on a un frère jumeau
noir est ce que ça te juste attendre la
fin de la campagne foutent de ma gueule
après on peut peut-être sa logique ne
sont pas de maillot le chauffeur
auxiliaires anthony enchanté
on peut comprendre et moi s'ils sont pas
c'est pas détendu et quand je suis pas
détendu j'ai tendance à trop parler
très bien que c'est sympa notre un peu
de musique j'ai un truc à te dire on est
frères au [ __ ]
je te colle à ce qu'ils ont claqué la
porte au nez grâce aux personnes à bas
revenu allant
soit je suis ton frère sûr je suis une
maladie honteuse n'a vraiment faucheuse
et tous de se rencontrer nos parents en
concert je vois le genre de musique
classique telus lumineux une même que
nagui klein qui la pub c'était une frite
on sait le mieux dans ces thèmes et
c'est quoi ton histoire du jounal à
écouter un frère jumeau et c'est gregor
beaulieu c'est une dingue une
fatigue et lui
continue comme ça qui va se passer dans
le mur qu'est-ce d'angoise c'est
impressionnant mais personne ne meurt il
a subi un choc émotionnel a récemment
reste calme je suis très calme waouh
dans ton cul
[Musique]
bah il a appris qu'il avait un frère
jumeau rapidement donné à la naissance
plus du moment je vois pas
mon dieu c'est compliqué
en tout cas moi dans l'histoire j'ai la
chance pour moi parce que j'avais une
chance sur deux d'être toi